ich bin gerade am flughafen angekommen
und sehr bald heben wir ab in richtung
libanon die junge bloggerin lea suter
hat ihre jobs bei der uno und beim
außenpolitischen thinktank voraus an den
nagel gehängt
nun startet sie ein neues projekt auf
eigene faust
[Musik]
in diesem jahr will er suter in zwölf
ehemalige konfliktgebiete reisen und
über erfolgreiche friedensprojekte will
ich die sprints heißt ihr blog und die
erste station ist die stadt tripoli im
norden des libanon anstoß für das
projekt die überwiegend negative
berichterstattung der medien über
krisengeschüttelte regionen
[Musik]
positive geschichte hervorbringen und
was wir vernachlässigt wird schauplatz
serie street im herzen von tripoli die
straße bildet eine trennlinie zwischen
dem alevitischen und dem sunnitischen
stadtteil bis vor zwei jahren haben die
menschen quer über die straße
aufeinander geschossen
heute sichert eine hohe militärpräsenz
den fragilen frieden
auf dieser serie street kann sich lea
suter nur mit personenschutz bewegen
[Musik]
wir haben gerade von dieser militär man
die erlaubnis erhalten hier zu drehen
das heißt zehn meter in dieser richtung
und sehnen die anderen filmen nein
in ihrem blog berichtet leas mutter von
ihren persönlichen eindrücken auf der
reise
manche eigenheiten dieser region erkennt
sie erst vor ort so richtig mit prinz
william super lokale friedensaktivisten
porträtieren
derzeit finanziert sie ihr projekt aus
eigener tasche
entsprechend eng ist der zeitplan vor
ort das will ausgenützt sei ein besuch
in der altstadt von tripoli kann die
kultur und geschichte der region
verständlich machen der kultur aktives
trale tab erzählt der bloggerin über den
großen wandel in seine stadt
durchgemacht hat
denn tripoli hat sich in den letzten 30
jahren von einer weltoffenen
multikulturellen metropole zu einer
hochburg konservativer soliden gewandelt
gegen diese entwicklung kämpft an
vorderster front
man kennt mich in tripoli ich bin anwalt
und obwohl die leute wissen dass ich
agnostiker bin und den radikalen islam
bekämpfe lieben sie mich diese jungen
männer haben zum teil in radikalen
gruppen in syrien gekämpft dass wir nun
trotz dieser differenzen freunde werden
können das ist ein bedeutender handel
sinnbild für diesen wandel ist das
kulturcafé hand in hand an der cbot
hier treffen unterschiedliche weltbilder
aufeinander
aleviten und sunniten vereint sondern
tisch vor zwei jahren noch undenkbar
möglich gemacht hat das die
nichtregierungsorganisation marge unter
der leitung von lehrer rudi sie ist
verantwortlich für die vielen
kulturellen aktivitäten die die bewohner
der ehemals verfeindeten quartiere ins
café locken am abend versammeln sich die
männer aus den beiden quartieren kaffee
man feiert in startschuss zum
wiederaufbau der serie die organisation
mag hilft in vielen ladenbesitzern ihr
gewerbe an der straße wieder auf
vordermann zu bringen
ich bin so so vom quartier la palma sinn
und das ist mein freund athris vom
quartier battle tabelle
wir sind hier um im wiederaufbauprojekt
mitzuhelfen wir wollen unsere läden
renovieren und dieser gegend zu ihrem
alten glanz verhelfen damit wir wieder
arbeiten und geld verdienen kann
diese beiden quartiere sollen wieder
eines werden so wie vor dem krieg
konkrete probleme finden über kultur
ihren weg zu frieden lösungen genau
danach sucht leas mutter für ihren ps
blog
es ist großartig mit dem projekt eine
art wahrscheinlich ist ideal projekt ist
das nicht würde ich eigentlich
vorgefunden hat uns mehr finanzieren
dann bestätigen dass die suche nach
frieden spuren bei sprints der suter hat
ihr neues lebensprojekt gestartet
[Musik]